I think as I say I think comedy is kind
of like hip-hop like when we talk about
like the goats there's like eras like to
me like rock him
might not have like well listen rockin's
a bad example but like if you go back to
like maybe like Run DMC right like Run
DMC like started this [__] yeah Run DMC
musically or maybe even lyrically might
not necessarily be on the same level as
Kendrick Lamar but their significance to
the cultures
uh
as great or greater yeah I mean but on
the comedy side who would you say this
era of Comedy is like on the on like
let's say since you've been like super
active let's say the last 15 to 20 years
like who would you put on the Mount
Rushmore uh so I would say
put uh
Dave
Chappelle yeah
uh
we put uh
Patrice O'Neal oh yeah rest in peace
uh uh let me put uh
uh
they put uh I don't know Wise persons uh
let me see then Chris Rock oh yes Chris
and uh who's a fourth oh and then
let me see
who's who's it for listen strictly off
the last 20. the last 20. the last 20 of
stand up yeah nice stand-up output
so you tell me okay so that's 2003 to
now
uh yeah one more slide hmm
uh
thanks for pay out Patrice O'Neal
Chris Rock
Tucker Carlson for the fourth
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Tucker Carlson my goodness that's for
the house I like it so this is gonna be
something
we're gonna need you to sign that we're
gonna frame it we're gonna put it right
on the side
oh you know
yeah there we go there it is there it is
yeah
you know what's crazy is like taco
Carlsen [__] is like
I just remember back in the day like Jon
Stewart roasting him with his little
[__] bow tie on like I think he was
on CNN then
and like it's just
he's a goof for sure yeah I don't even
and I don't you don't have to tell me I
don't even know exactly what happened I
just know they were like Tucker Carson's
out it's crazy because it happened the
same day that Don Lemon got fired okay
yeah I was I I was watching um
Roy Wood Jr the The Correspondents he
killed the oh yeah he killed it but it
was a few things that I was just finding
out from him
like wait a minute let me yeah I don't
get the joke even the uh the uh the nft
the Clarence Thomas joke was was really
funny but I didn't know that that
situation was going on it was just yeah
a lot of news he did his thing on there
he said I want to say did he used to do
prank calls back he's a prank calls back
that's how I started in 99. I want to
say I had like a CD of his prank calls
his prank calls were [__] epic that's
how he built his uh following initially
out of it's out of Birmingham yeah yeah
bro he's dope man yeah Roy super dope
man yeah
um for you man like uh is there any of
the up and coming artists or current
artists in hip-hop that you could like
inspired by I know you we just had
Courtney's manager here you were in his
videos there anybody who's like you know
kind of in that era of music that you
actually like because a lot of this [__]
is terrible uh it's a lot of it's a lot
of good stuff there's a lot of good
stuff a lot of good stuff out there
um
you know
it's more on r b but I just heard it uh
the other day you know Jordan Ward I
heard it I've heard the name I haven't
he got some good tracks man his album
um
I one of them one of the songs popped up
on my Discover and then I listened to
the rest of the album but it sounds good
well produced Leto who's a really dope
producer
um produced a lot of it uh
uh his flow is crazy loves me
I mean
it's
who else is newer that
trying to think of folks man
no smino's fire yeah yeah yeah that's
that like that flow is is one of those
things we like I don't know I don't know
how that's happening
some people you like that's dope but
then there's some people I don't
understand how that's happening right
now yeah have you uh take take me back
as somebody who had high interest in
comedy High interest in music how dope
was it like
was there uh when the double XL cover
came out with Dave Chappelle Dead Prez I
want to say Kanye was on there Tele
quality was on there
he did such a good job of bringing the
Two Worlds together with the Chappelle
show and just I just think of that
vampire and the block party and I just
it was amazing like like for you like
how how it you know important was that
as an up-and-coming comedian who's also
obviously an artist like
he did such a good job I think of I
really feel like he successfully
bridged like two eras of comedy and
music together definitely man it's just
how he he brings people together with
his shows and and and performances
uh it's been cool to to really watch I
snuck into a Chappelle Show years back
when I was
in Chicago I think it was 0-4005 when
he's doing stand-up yeah it's the height
of Chappelle Show Congress Theater and I
didn't have money for a ticket I tried
to and it was I was just started I've
tried to like go in and like I'm a
comedian like that doesn't no one cares
nobody cares so I just started looking
around the building just found an Open
Door got in and got in and uh
so it was did I was wow and then the you
know years later do a lot of shows with
him uh it made it super surreal like
damn I used to sneak in your [__] he's
super cool too yeah I got really high
with him once uh it was actually a core
Days album release party
it was me Dave Chappelle
and uh
the guy who played Steve Urkel
Jaleel
White yeah and I was like
this is inter like what is happening
right now yeah man someone told me as a
12 year old I'd be in a [__] joint
circle with Dave Chappelle and Steve her
I had a Steve Urkel toy as a kid like I
pull this did I do that like yeah it's
crazy man life is made up man stuff be
happening yeah uh when do you plan on
putting out this this album man
July July Target is July 21st
um
and then
looking to do I'm doing sobs June 14th
hey that's a big deal for any up and
coming hip-hop artist to do an SOB show
I'm I'm hyped about it man just you know
I've performed there years back 10 years
ago [__] what uh
uh with chance actually I just stand up
for a chance massive rap 2013 yeah
um they just celebrated the birthday of
that so shout out to chance
and so I'm yeah I'm hyped to do sobs man
you're headlining yeah headline I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do the you know stand
up and music set so I do stand up at the
beginning special guests and stuff and
who's opening for you a comedian or an
artist uh
I think I'm gonna have one comedian one
artist hmm uh uh maybe a couple artists
probably have my guy highlight Supreme
this dope singer he produced one of my
track knee brace and
uh the Southern Track Paradox uh on my
project and so he's amazing performer he
actually he giving me little tips in the
studio where he'll say hey you got a
smile right you're recording they can
hear it they can hear it through the mic
they can hear it through the mic and so
I'll do a take and resounding and so
I'll be doing a take and then it'll
sound flat
and then I'll read I'll re-cut and and
smile and it sound completely different
than you think that's true yeah that's
somewhere I mean that's like the little
[__] like that yeah you gotta you kind
of know from being in the studio so much
if he just he'll he'll stand in front of
you like hey man
like doing warm-up [__] and so it's
always just tough to learn from folks
it's always something to to learn from
and and and improve as far as the studio
and the show man
um so you it's gonna be in I'm I'm the
show gonna be on on point sobs wins a
day SOB's June 14th are you gonna do
anything in L.A
I'm gonna do something I I'm trying to
do the Moroccan it might be in the fall
but I'm in La I don't have anything set
but I'll do something in La soon
probably around the album drop better be
dope yeah
um I always wonder like with the you
know we always hear about like how it's
a little harder to do certain jokes
nowadays because we'll get offended yeah
I think a lot of that's a little
blown out of proportion but you know it
we are in a much more sensitive climate
a much more divisive climate right do
you think it's a lot harder for
stand-up comedians nowadays
I can't speak to it like for real in the
mo you know because I'm not living it in
the same way even like two or three
years ago like you know like I feel like
it's just like
people get I just I feel like people are
all as much as they want to laugh they
also want to get offended nowadays you
your [__] man you know what I mean like
that ain't gonna really you know it's
always
as many people as if people offended
there's gonna be other people that want
that type of stuff so you just worry
about your show worry about who's there
and and just write and perform to the
best of your ability and instincts and
that's that's the gig